we have yet another
potential Trump criminal Scandal on our
hands Donald Trump's Saudi Arabia
payments are sparking fresh calls for a
sparking calls for a fresh investigation
writes you and Palmer for Newsweek
let's take a look at this article Donald
Trump should be investigated over the
payments he received to host the Saudi
arabia-backed live golf tour at his
Resorts according to an organization set
up by supporters of the murder
journalist Jamal khashoggi the Democracy
for the Arab world now group has called
for the doj and Congress to look into
the quote disturbing facts and
circumstances surrounding that golf tour
and ties to Trump on January 13th it was
revealed during court proceedings that
the Saudi Arabia public investment fund
that's the Sovereign wealth fund headed
by the country's Crown Prince Mohammed
bin Salman owns 93 percent of Live And
pays 100 of the costs Don claims this is
the first time that the full extent of
The Sovereign wealth fund's ownership in
live golf has been disclosed understand
that this uh it immediately points to
money transfers from the Saudi royal
family through that Sovereign wealth
fund to Trump by virtue of paying to
host the live golf tournaments at
Trump's golf courses including
Bedminster in 2022. this potentially
relates to money laundering this
potentially relates to an influence scam
and of course all of the answers to what
we are looking for are found in
Hunter Biden's laptop right that must be
the answer no um listen in all
seriousness
we all suspected this
we all suspected that this golf
tournament and Saudi Arabia and this
goes beyond just the United States this
was a mechanism to transfer huge amounts
of money
it could be to trump it could be to
other other world leaders because there
are live golf tournaments in various
places and when we talk about Trump and
influence peddling it already is
it's beyond the pale
that trumps Washington D.C hotel is not
the subject of more scrutiny because
during Trump's presidency that hotel was
a Nexus of massive money transfers and
emoluments that were received by Trump
world leaders looking to ingratiate
themselves with Donald Trump saying hey
well I'll stay at Trump's hotel and I'll
mention that I'm staying at Trump's
hotel that it's it's a it's a borderline
crime that that hasn't been further
investigated but this one was so obvious
this is so obvious Trump was criticized
for hosting a bunch of different lift
golf events at his Resorts but we didn't
understand the full scope of what is
essentially the royal family owning this
entire thing Saudi royal family controls
the Sovereign wealth fund Sovereign
wealth fund owns 93 of the golf
tournament and pays 100 of those costs
this is
um the Revelation in practice that
millions of dollars dollars from the
Saudis have been going not in terms of
arms deals arms deals are bad enough but
at least they are public or semi-public
this was a subterfuge of sorts there
should be another investigation and it
is exhausting to even keep up with this
the other aspect to the Saudi Trump
connection is of course Jared Kushner
and Jared kushner's role and connections
and relationships with these very same
folks involved in The Sovereign wealth
fund are we ever going to know the full
scope I don't believe we are
I don't know that we are ever going to
unwind everything that went on during
those insane four years but one of the
things we can do is do everything within
our power to prevent there being another
four years just like it make sure you
are subscribed on YouTube to the David
Pacman show at youtube.com the David
Pacman show we really need your help
something is happening on YouTube with
the algorithm where it's not just the
David Pacman show many channels like
ours are being de-prioritized it has
been years since we have talked about
this because it has not been an issue
for years
something is happening systematically to
a half dozen channels like ours and it
seems to be algorithmic so the best
thing you can do leave a comment
like our videos and make sure that you
are indeed subscribed we're going to
take a quick break and the Friday show
rolls on right after this